new in theaters this weekend bad boys
for life and Doolittle what will you see
this is your weekend ticket no never
y'all will never do that again yeah and
you delirious which take a long time and
learn in this third and final
installment of the trilogy Marcus and
Mike have all but moved on from being
bad boys together and Marcus seems about
to retire
but a mob boss whose brother they
defeated previously makes it personal
and the boys must come together one more
time this movies for you if you're a fan
of the previous two bad boys films
you're looking for an action comedy this
weekend or you're excited to see Will
Smith and Martin Lawrence team up one
last time unless they make another one
then it's second to last time we've got
you can talk to animals
the reclusive dr. John Dolittle played
by Robert Downey jr. must once again
emerge and use his ability to speak to
any animal be it land air or sea
creature as he sets off on an adventure
to a mythical island to save a dying
Queen Doolittle features an all-star
voice cast for the animals including
Emma Thompson rami malek John Cena the
Mel Nanjiani Octavia Spencer Tom Holland
Craig Robinson ray Fiennes Selena Gomez
and Marion Cotillard this movies for you
if you're looking for a movie for the
whole family this weekend you can't wait
to see the cast ham it up as their
animals or you're excited to see Robert
Downey jr. and Tom hall and team up
again kind of that is your weekend
ticket what will you see and come back
next week for the gentlemen